your dad you know you're doing these
book signings now and people come to see
you and and and they want to meet you
and they want to buy the book and I
thought it was very sweet you're very
close to your family you brought your
dad along I did who I was in Chicago
last week I said dad you want to come to
the book signings like oh yeah let's go
so we go and I'm signing books I open up
the book and it's already signed it says
stay hungry always Salvatore man ask
uncle's my bear I go what he's got his
own wine this really he's signing he's
personalizing I'm I'm trying to crank
them out with just a signature he's like
where you're from Arlington Heights okay
nice guy from Arlington Heights Sabha
what are you doing so he's gonna make it
he's also making you look bad yeah
people can see him do that they're gonna
want you to do course they were like
could you personalize mine your father
did yeah he's not even involved in this
we have a picture of him this is really
true someone took this big
you talk a lot you talk a lot on stage
about your dad and he comes across as a
very frugal guy is that it that's a
polite way to say it he's frugal he's
always looking for a bargain I was
looking for a deal
I found out he served two years in the
army that he gets a discount for
veterans so he came up to LA and we go
into a little mom-and-pop store it's
like a liquor store and he's like get
the bisque on there and they're like I'm
sorry for what I mean he was in the army
yeah like they're supposed to know yeah
yeah
he planned out his funeral already found
out that the army gives him a free
burial so now we got to go six hours
away to the military cemetery for a free
coffin and plot so that's how far into
this he is now wait a minute
what did he do in the army he was in
there for two years he never served any
like he was he was like a cook so he was
a cook in the army I get it he served
but when he's so vocal and yeah angry
about it yeah that it's embarrassing
when I'm with them because he's always
you know it's it's not it's never like
here's my discount I served in the
United States mail
[Laughter]
how is he how is he with the fans I mean
he must he loves that you're so
successful but how is he would he when
he meets the fans besides signing books
he had nothing to do with what's he like
yeah and while the fans some fans showed
up on his porch last week and he calls
me up he's like yeah yeah yeah I'll let
some of your fans in the house I go wow
yeah four women came by with some
meatballs and cookies and you know I had
some Michael you ate the food now listen
people bring me food all the time like
hey there's some cake is it right in the
garbage okay I see the food I actually
poison right that's a pretty paranoid
thing to think well this is kind of like
this is my dad taught me this but now
he's going completely against his own
rules right so he's he sold them two
books he saw what he sells yeah he sold
him the two books and he ate some
meatballs and cookies and he brought him
to the salon he's a he's a hairdresser
so he's got a book display at the salon
and you get like the dye job and a book
that's fantastic so you don't eat the
food when fans give you food you don't
need it no would you I mean listen if
somebody and not need to get you guys
but if you brought them some cookies you
can eat them
I'd eat every single one
I've been in this business a long time I
know how to play this game stay hungry
this is such a fantastic story yes stay
hungry is is in stores right now or you
can go to your dad's salon yeah better
off going to the dad salon you get a
better price there than you do it and
what he's doing go see him again sure
you one thing he's not keeping the books
on this books off the books
you